everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse today we're gonna do some work on
our fonts so I mentioned a few times
that at some point I was going to change
change our fonts kind of mess around a
little bit with font sizes font colors
font weights and try to find something
that that really works with this layout
so that's we're gonna work on today I
just want to take a minute to show some
of the pool requests that we've got and
so we're all on the same page with where
we're at here the let's see so Sebastian
and the hard [ __ ] both submitted pool
requests Sebastian did some work with
the padding here at the bottom of the
cards so that's a lot nicer also with
the colors we had several different
colors for our click effects here now
it's it's all grey so at least it's
consistent I'm still considering maybe
changing the color but the consistency
is a big improvement and sorry if I'm
missing something
Sebastian something else in the pool
request there were several things kind
of lumped together in there now Harshit
spool request is is interesting so this
is a filter filter and you could filter
by by month year so let's let's take a
look at how it works so we're gonna go
to the current bulletin so we have
everything up here and here's the thing
about the filter though right now see if
I can grab I want to try to get it to a
date that will actually work so let's
try this what is that April May May 2016
let's go May 2016 okay great so see all
these posts are from May of 2016
awesome
let's go and then you can actually go
back if you want to and submit and then
you get everything but here's what I
note I did notice one slight bug so I
don't know if anybody caught that when I
went back and selected none for these
and submitted
I'm let's see actually I got it let me
go back to the category here let me just
demonstrate this again so we're gonna
search for February stuff okay nothing
in February now if you want to go back
and submit we get everything even though
we're on category two and if I click
category three I still have everything
still of everything on categorized of
everything if I click see I gotta
actually click all and then back so that
is potentially an unlikely bug someone
would have to first pick a category and
then want to filter by date within that
category and then select none and submit
again but at that point potentially it
can be confusing so I'm gonna say that
it's definitely a bug but it's not a
very likely bug
it's very for anyone to encounter but
you know it's something to think about
maybe we'll work on that I definitely
put that in a list of maybe things that
would be nice to have before we launch
but not 100% necessary unless somebody
really wants to do that then that's
that's great
some things that maybe I'd like I'm I'm
wondering about the button here I don't
know I don't really know how I feel
about having a button in the side the
side nav
just from like a look perspective the
alternative would be maybe try to go
with a different style but and see if
that looks a little bit nicer or
potentially just have the search happen
on change I think it could be reasonable
if someone would want to search an
entire year but not reasonable that
someone would want to search every let's
say February no matter what year it is I
don't know what do you think about that
so we'll see my thought is basically you
can have a check so in the live site
where I'm doing this basically it just
checks to make sure that these are
selected and then it only does the
search if you select the month and a
year although as we get further along I
could see the value and wanting to
select only the year and make that an
option right now
I guess we're coming up on 2018 so you
know potentially that's that's more
legitimate than when I first made it so
anyway there's just a few things to
think about maybe to customize this a
bit so I welcome your your opinions on
that and maybe I'll try to get some user
data for for some of the some of the
real users and see like have they been
using this I actually had a user call
earlier today and asked me how to find
something from a previous bulletin so a
previous month and so it was actually
helpful although I reck really the
search function would have been the most
helpful in that use case but there was
there was a desire to be able to search
by date so anyway good work hardship
yeah definitely helpful and like I said
so have that kind of
minor minor bug but I went ahead merged
it in anyway because it it fits the
functionality of what we wanted and like
I said I I don't even know that that the
odds of that even ever happening are
probably small so I think it's good to
go
merge into master and you know then
every you know we can all work from that
so let me check the live chat quickly
before we get started with our fonts
oh okay Harshit saying recommending to
not use material you I and further
projects it was a nightmare
I was almost who lose my money alright I
mean I'm open to other things we just
need to find a material design framework
that has what we want and what we need
so I mean within material UI we have two
options we have the older one and then
the newer beta and then potentially
there's others out there it's just a few
projects ago when we were checking
around material you I was I'll say the
most complete solution that we found out
there maybe things have changed so if
anybody else is using a material design
component library for react let me know
let me know what you think about it
harsh it's been having a rough time I I
don't know I I there are some minor
annoyances with it but I don't think I'm
I haven't used it enough to make a good
judgment I would think I would need to
really learn how it works a little bit
more before I make a judgement about the
beta version of mature UI I know I have
had to kind of adjust some things here
and there because I didn't quite like
how things worked but so far it has
served its purpose but like I said I am
open to trying other things okay
oh that's right Sebastian also changed
the print view so now the close icon has
moved to the right probably just a few
things about the print view I'll
probably end up taking out these
horizontal lines because in in the print
view I think it's it breaks it up on
first glance it seems like this is
supposed to break up between posts but
it's really not it's between this is all
one post with a line in the middle
so either we'd remove the lines
completely or we'd have to move the line
below attachment also I think I'd like
to have some some padding on the sides I
think that would be good and then
potentially I would maybe want this
close icon to line up more with how we
have the menu icon so in terms of
positioning but otherwise the print view
is I mean even now at this point the
print view is fulfilling its function
you know these are just kind of small
details that I would like to see so I'll
either work on that at another time or
another stream or anyone else can work
on it if they like
okay I think so sheshank saying I
believe about the print view that each
post and a tile well the the idea here
with the print view is to be as
minimalist as possible but we want to
optimize it for print so the less we
have to print the the better so I'm kind
of leaning towards just completely
removing this and instead making sure
that there's a reasonable amount of
padding between each post you know for
instance we would tighten this up so
that the attachment name was really
close to this maybe you know no more
than eight pixels between the
attachments and the attachment name you
know but between the posts no less than
16 pixels you know possibly more we'd
have to see so you know I'm just kind of
thinking like it adds up if somebody's
printing this out maybe a lot of posts
every week you know all these lines take
ink right so anyway so in this case
really the way it looks on the web is is
entirely secondary to the way it would
print out so that's what you want to
keep in mind for that okay well let's
get started I'll come back to the live
chat and go over anything if I've missed
anything but we're pretty about 15
minutes into the stream and we haven't
gotten to we've done I mean we had to
get caught up on some of the changes
obviously but now I'd like to start my
Pomodoro clock where you need 25 minutes
of in of coding in this case we're going
to be you know mainly working with CSS
and some of the built-in features of
material UI okay
so first thing I want to do is work on
this the this by far is going to be the
the font that is seen and used
throughout the site more than any
other font okay so we're gonna work on
this but then we're also going to visit
this sidebar we're gonna we're gonna
look at you know the headache headings
depending on how much time we have and
how long it takes we're gonna look at
every bit of font on this site but first
let's deal with this because if we only
get one thing done today this is gonna
have the biggest impact so here's what
I'd like to see I would definitely like
that font to be bigger and I I kind of
I'm not a huge fan of the font weight so
let's just play with it a little bit I
know in a previous in a previous stream
we had worked with what was built in
with material UI in terms of font styles
but I really think I'd like to customize
it exactly how how I want it it's nice
that material UI has those built in but
it's really not that big of a deal to
change some fonts with with CSS so some
font sizes and weights so I think in
this case we'll get a better result if
we just customize it ourselves so let's
go into dev tools and we'll just play
around a little bit with the fonts now
I've also had the idea of bringing in
that responsive font from materialized
CSS that we've used on previous projects
so that's still an option I'm a little
afraid that it might be too big people
are used to a font that's somewhere in
between this and what we're using when
we use that responsive font from
materialise so we'll see
oh that's interesting why is that in an
aside tag really interesting okay well
let's bring this up so we can see what's
going on here and let's take that font
size and I want it to be at least 16
pixels I don't want us to have any fonts
that are smaller than 16 pixels let's go
with font weights
let's try 400 yeah I like that a lot
better do you see that that difference
will be able to you know side by side
see the difference but already I think
this is amis room in here I don't know
about you but at least on my screen
already I see a big difference in terms
of readability this just seems a lot
nicer so let's let's keep going with
this I do want to check what do we have
a color okay I like that color we have
that this is the correct way to do color
with material design on the web black
with some transparency particularly 0.87
for your primary text okay all right
that's not bad let's try to bring this
up though let's see if it will still be
reasonable what I'm going to zoom out so
that we see what it's really like would
it be reasonable to go up to let's say
18
I think 18 I think 18 looks nice
all right let me go back let me see the
live chat what do you all think I I
don't think 18 looks too large at all
okay it looks like John Hanson says
lighter font-weight I find much easier
on my eyes especially my old eyes haha
yeah that's I mean that's gonna go for
really you know for somebody who's I I
mean for somebody that has perfect
vision right it's who carry the font
size doesn't really matter they're gonna
deal with font size no matter what but
I'm more worried about you know there's
going to be a lot of older people
reading this we certainly have
especially among the faculty here you
know there there are some some older
professors that I want to make sure that
they're able to read this so I kind of
want to go beyond you know just the
normal use case
okay all right sheshank thinks actually
that the 18 pixel font is a little bit
is it's clogging actually I would like
to see maybe let me apply this 18 pixels
and then see how it all lays out because
right now you know we're doing this
within the card so you see it's kind of
going over we really aren't going to
know until we see everything like that
so let's go ahead and try this and yeah
we'll try this let me see okay so this
is not that's just really interesting I
would have assumed that this was somehow
in a paragraph tag and not an aside
that's an interesting does anyone know
should this be in an aside is there any
benefit to that and is there any way we
can change that since you know we're not
actually creating this tag directly it's
it's being created by material UI
let's see how I want to select this
Mui card content receipt all the the
classes are they're not helping me right
now I guess I could just do all the
sides okay Brett says a side is good
semantically okay cool I just I really
haven't used the side very much so I
just wanted to make sure that you know
it was the right way to use it I'm glad
that it works I wasn't really looking
forward to digging into that component
and trying to change it okay so let's go
with that let's let's go to our just our
index dot CSS I would like these styles
to apply over a wide range of things so
this is I think the the proper place
let's see
let's go with P and a side and we'll add
this in let's save that and we'll the
wrong way I guess we need to refresh
ourselves okay I suppose we're getting
overridden here let's see what's going
on
yep we are so we're gonna have to I
really hate to use important on
something that's this kind of global and
our styles but I really also don't want
to have to go into every place and and
put these things in so let's see
let's see alright so hard saying you
styled ijs alright let's check out our
style da Jas I mean at this point we're
pretty much still testing it out as well
so I'm all for putting things in the
right place but we're almost like
designing as we code so I guess I could
just do it in dev tools I guess I don't
have style dodge ass open currently so
let's grab it from here
okay
let's see what yes I'm just wondering
what is their class already being
applied that we could just add on to see
these are all have these numbers added
okay
okay or I should say an open post
preview I will check it out
okay so at least this being applied here
which is nice it's not bad actually in
post preview we have quite a bit of
space we could probably go larger if we
really wanted to hmm I think this is
fine for now but we definitely have that
opportunity
okay
all right um I think I'm okay yeah I'm
okay with that for now let's go back to
this view and we also do want to make
sure that we don't forget to check this
view as well all right so let's check
out we have one on here I guess I could
check into the okay large should I you
keep saying I mean the Jay s file oh
okay
the component post preview okay so not
be sorry I thought you meant go to the
post preview and not be components oh
yeah those preview
hmm
hmm Harsha says see their card contents
yeah do we did we have card content
okay
our concept
there we go okay so here's what we're
pulling in that that content okay
so
I don't know I'm thinking here
since we haven't found a typography type
that we like for this should we even be
using typography could we get
I mean ought we to just use a paragraph
tag or should support
did you really submit a pull request
already on this are you saying check the
pool request when we did this
so I'm actually interested to see we
would have to switch it up because we
can't just pop content well I suppose we
could because we've already sanitized it
so we could put it like that let's see
we could I mean we could just add a
class on it
are we already using classes content
who did
okay yes hardship is submitted upon
request basically doing what we were
doing here so we're we add so what we're
doing here now is we're gonna keep the
typography and we're gonna add a class
okay
then up here what we have all our
classes here then we can just add that
class in and we'll put in our our CSS as
if as an array or I'm sorry as an object
so you can see there are several ways to
do styles and react
all right we're we're using a mixture so
we're doing some some normal CSS here
right this is should be very familiar
which works in reacts it's it's it's
totally fine it it works but there are
some other ways this being one of the
ways where we're actually making an
object and we're using that within our
within our components so this kind of
allows you to have a much more
self-contained component if you have all
the styles for your component and in the
actually in the component it's much
easier to just take that component and
reuse it anywhere right but if we put
all our Styles here and index of CSS
well number one they're all global which
which I mean global styles aren't in
themselves bad but it can be bad there
can be conflicts it can be difficult to
manage
so anyway depending on what you what
project you're doing and you know how
you want to organize it you may want to
do these there might there are other
ways as well these aren't the only ways
to do it okay I will say this though if
you do it this way
I find it easier to transition to react
native because this is the way you'll
you'll most likely want to do this and
react native with slight differences but
we did a stream on react native if you
want to know more about those
differences but it's a much easier
transition so if you just kind of start
learning it this way it's a little bit
weird at first to get used to making it
as an object and there are ways to
actually put real CSS in here in terms
of syntax as well if you really want
want to do it like that
but anyway that's we're going to do so I
know we kind of almost had it done here
but I don't want harsh it's work to go
to waste so I'm gonna bring in his pull
request just really quickly and get rid
of what I was doing here and just so
that I don't have to deal with any merge
stuff right now whoops there we go I'm
gonna get rid of everything that we've
done
here we go so let's just double check
its status no index the CSS has changed
what did I change
there we go all right I said better now
it's probably just indentation actually
that's really weird why do I have that
indented like that I never indent things
like that this is really weird
indentation
okay anyway let's just I guess it
doesn't matter now
nah mr. Oh up all right let's go with
this key tag again since I do want this
to apply to all paragraphs no matter
what anyway we use a mixer both both
ways what was it
font size 18 and font weights 400 and I
may end up changing this as well I'm
thinking it might not be a bad idea to
do the responsive font for the paragraph
tags and then go with a standard font
for that post preview the cards so
that's probably what I'm gonna end up
doing I doubt I have time on this
Pomodoro session maybe on the next
session we'll do that but anyway let's
just or let's just can make this quickly
and
this would be a little bit more
descriptive
there we go
so I had blocked my live chat
see
okay hard [ __ ] thanks for that I always
forget that you could just if I wanted
to just revert everything without
manually doing it I could have just done
get checkout and then a dot so that
would have been faster thanks let me
check my time okay
perfect timing we'll just finish this up
and now I can merge great and awesome so
now we have all of our stuff we're gonna
see it now great okay so here's what it
looks like with the size 18 font I
something needs something could be
better
maybe it's the line height maybe line I
know we can we can do better it just
seems something's off all right let's
let me take five minutes now and go
through the the live chat answer any
questions you have then we'll do another
session and I think I'm gonna I'm gonna
check out some previous work that we've
done and just compare what we're doing
in terms of line height because that may
be that may be what seems off to me here
okay so let me scroll up and I'll try to
get through as much as I can in this
five minutes
okay so red 23 as a question do you
think that hTML is easier than Python
yeah for somebody who has no experience
in any type of coding at all
or web development I do think HTML would
be easier to learn now if you already
have a background in programming like
let's say another programming language
you know maybe you're in a Java or some
form of C it it actually this may sound
weird but I think it actually might be
easier to go with Python than to learn
HTML and I wouldn't normally think this
except I I I dunno I've talked to at
least one programmer who was always used
to doing just strictly like software
development with with c-sharp and trying
to learn more front-end stuff like HTML
it was actually somewhat challenging
because it's a whole different mindset
so you know it's hard to to measure you
know what what's easier or not easier
you know what what unit of measurement
is there for that
but I would say the majority of the time
hTML is easier but it's somewhat depends
on what background you're coming from in
terms of your knowledge base
okay not really a lot of questions going
on hon so sorry for the long pause I'm
just trying to read through and see see
if I need to answer anything so all
harsh it says no date is now on LTS so
yeah if if you haven't upgraded your
version of node for a while now might be
a good time to go up to Note 8 I know in
particular for this project it will not
work unless you have at least node 7 for
I think so seven point four so not a bad
time to upgrade
oh good good question Joseph asks if
there's a print view for individual
posts and yes there is so if we click an
individual post and then hit print view
we have our print view here so actually
now that I think about it I don't think
this is a really important you know it's
not a priority but you know it's
possible that we could do a little bit
with with this section here to make it
more printer friendly so like obviously
I wouldn't want any color in the print
view because most likely it's going to
be printed black and white anyway yeah
we'll see I mean I think this is
acceptable as is but well maybe we'll
come back to that at some point but
anyway good question
okay
Danann jay says learning and Stanford
online cs101 course says is it is it
worth learning yeah I think having a
basic knowledge of computer sciences is
very useful even even just if you're
doing web development is it necessary
for web development no not it's not
necessary but I think it it could
definitely be helpful and it makes it
easier for you to kind of branch out and
maybe go into different things if you
don't want to stick with web development
because you have that background and
kind of a better view of the big picture
in terms of all of you know the computer
science realm so I think that's awesome
I haven't checked out that Stanford 101
course I have done a bit of the Harvard
cs50 course and I thought that was very
interesting if I have time I'd love to
finish that I've just got got busy with
other projects but no I I think it's if
you had the time to do it it's it's
worthwhile all right
let's go back
okay let me go back and let's start our
Pomodoro session and we're going to
let's go ahead oh okay now I remember
that we were gonna do we were going to
check out this spacing there's just
something about this that's that I don't
like right now so we're gonna check that
out oh okay heart shouldn't mentioned it
I I had said I thought it was 7.4 for
the node version we actually need 7.6
and that's because we're using async
await on the server so we need at least
seven point six so if you try to I
believe we have this in the
documentation for the project so I think
it is in there but in case you you
didn't read that and you're having
trouble getting the project to work on
your own machine make sure you have the
correct node version okay
all right let me check out actually I
want to check this out on the current
bulletin so I'm on my other screen I'm
just gonna bring out dev tools just to
check quickly what what kind of styles
were we have here on our and and the
current bullets and these are paying
paragraph tags but okay so I want line I
wish our line I ain't gonna from one
place all right let's check our line I
here now
hmm that's a finite 24 are we getting
this yeah all right let's try some about
some different things with line height
so I'm basically running 1.5 is the line
height and let's see what that's changed
it to okay so let's see the difference
actually I really like that I don't I
don't know about you all but that just
at least for my eyes seeing this that
just made a big difference
not bad so I mean it was only a few
pixels different so we're going from 24
pixels in line I to 27 pixels but I I
think that makes a big difference
all right let's throw that in so there's
two places where I want to change this
right now because I think I'd like to
apply it to paragraphs as well so I'm
gonna try to keep using the setup I have
now for the paragraph tags although I
still might change it to use a
responsive font and by that I mean if
you're not familiar with a responsive
font the font size will actually change
based on the screen width so it'll be a
more optimal viewing experience
basically the idea is to keep the words
big enough to be readable and not only
that but the amount of words per line in
that sweet spot which is should I think
what it was I can't remember for sure
that with the optimal amount of words
per line is it's easy to Google and see
if anybody remembers what that is
please let me know in the live chat but
there there is actually an optimum
amount if you want people to be able to
read things easily on your site and it's
hard when you have multiple like
different size screens to actually get
that a responsive font can help you stay
within that range so it's an it doesn't
always work it's not perfect but you
have a much better shot at staying
within that range if you if you do it
like that so what I just do lion heights
25 and we're also gonna do it here so as
davia card class height 5 okay so it
should give us an auto refresh and let's
double check to make sure this is being
applied it definitely should be yep it
is wonderful and we can check in here
make sure it's applied as well and you
know did I forget to save it it's
possible
all right let's give it a refresh
oh there we go okay awesome
all right so this is acceptable right
now if we have time later on and we want
to keep messing with it we certainly can
let's go to this side now because aside
from the titles which right now I think
are acceptable I I may want to work on
them a bit but aside from that I just
want to make sure that everything we're
doing here in the side nav is it's all
you know as readable as it can be so I'm
not we may not have to do much but I
just want to double check a few things
and make sure so the first thing I want
to check is the font size we're 14 I
don't want to be at 14
so let's bump this up now - that's what
is this category yeah let's bump this up
and we're gonna go font font size 16
pixels okay yeah I think that's much
better it doesn't look like we're in any
danger of having you know something be
too long
everything's short enough here there
should work alright so let's go ahead
and do that I think this is component is
called the drawer so let's find that
maybe at war and here
yeah here so we're gonna have these
these list items and
because we can put it right on the link
we said we already have a class classes
link on here so let's edit that order so
that we doing this down on the bottom
there's our classes up okay where are we
passing in
I guess we're passing it in
hmm okay
index
sidebar okay that's what we're calling
I'm calling this sidebar where are we
bringing this in sideboard for let's
let's change this to be consistent with
our naming so I'm gonna change this to
drawer so anyway I guess this is good so
uh duh I mean I don't know if there's
some reason for doing it differently but
I think it's less confusing if in
general we we keep our component names
the same as the file names for our
components so that was throwing me a
little bit I was looking for a component
called drawer but instead it was it was
sidebar so we're gonna have to have some
sort of standard like guide for
contributing a style guide or something
like that so anyway so if you're here if
you're submitting pull requests just
keep that in mind otherwise you know it
can get a bit confusing but yeah we
didn't really have any type of formal
you know guidelines about that so we'll
have to add that end somewhere I think I
think we have a contributing file for
this repo I'm not positive though but
perhaps we should just have some sort of
global style guide that what that would
probably help things out class is this
first class okay so we're bringing in ok
Harsha says we're pulling that in from
style J s all right so let's grab that
oh yes right here right next to it okay
let's bring this
Oh hard [ __ ] good thinking
so he said he are [ __ ] named so harsh
had ended up naming that component side
bar instead of drawer because he didn't
want it to be confused with the drawer
component that is is brought in from
mature UI actually that makes a lot of
sense let me see
okay doesn't look oh you're pulling it
in anywhere else so okay so how about
this let's do like I said we'll have to
type this up and kind of do it formally
but how about if there could be some
conflict where you have we're using a
library that has the same component name
as the one that we're trying to create
our custom one can have the normal name
so in this case drawer and then if we do
want to use the libraries version
elsewhere or potentially even in the
same file we just prefix it so instead
of drawer it would be mui tour then that
way we can just keep using both if we
need to and there will be no confusion
about where that component comes from
because we're calling it mui drawer so
can we do that would that be doable and
easy or is that going to be should we do
it the opposite way and somehow prefix
our components and maybe say custom
drawer let me know what you think would
be easier we're more reasonable to do
I'm open to either one but it'd just be
cool if we could decide on one way and
then be consistent with it later on so I
mean I'm sure most of you can understand
and handle the distinction but you know
potentially if we get newer people who
are just learning react I'd like to try
to make it as easy of an experience as
possible if they're looking through our
code or trying to contribute and then
potentially if I get any student workers
here at the university that are dealing
with this they're likely going to be new
to react so anyway you all you
understand okay so we're sorry I just
lost my train of thought oh okay I was
trying to find where
what styles I need to bring in oh sorry
so we have aa drawer here classes with
uh singing this price classes
okay so basically I should be fine to
add a class here and then it'll just go
straight down right okay awesome
Harshit I'm gonna I'm gonna grab your
comment here and let's see I'm gonna put
it up here quickly just so everybody can
see it let me make sure no it's blocked
let's put it up higher
okay so this is pretty much this is what
we want to do so up here it might be
hard to see cuz it's grey but basically
we're we're running pick this up so
we're gonna do import drawer as NUI
drawer so in this case material I draw
but we could really prefix it with
different things depending on what
library we're using and then it'll be of
course from material UI / drawer so
excellent
cool I figured there was a way to do it
okay so let me see is see the class name
okay so let's just pass it down let's
find out where our other drawer classes
are just group them together so we have
drawer paper drawer header let's throw
in drawer item
yeah let's go draw item and then we're
gonna say fonts size 16 16 pixels let's
not forget that comma I've gotten so
many errors from forgetting commas and
this it's like it's so silly but it's
it's easy to forget that little comma
okay now let's go back in our drawer yes
let's go back down to our list classes
link oh okay we already had a class
shoot let me find that class link not
seeing it there we go
okay you know what for now I'm gonna
keep this separate I don't want to put
the because I assume this link color is
being could potentially be used in other
things and not necessarily the site site
now so so I'm just gonna apply both
styles here so I'm thinking later on if
in fact we do a responsive font I don't
want to risk conflicting so I would
potentially have all of the font one
size and then somehow have a link a
different size so anyway let's do where
we add drawer so let's go class name
classes link areas we do this I should
says use classname package to combine
styles okay how do we do that I was just
gonna pass both styles in so I'm
interested in this so harsh it's saying
we can use classname package to combine
styles but I am unfamiliar with this
okay
okay interesting I think I've never done
it like that before I've done like like
an array within here of of classes I
think that's how I did it I think it was
gonna write see the ECC at bar okay
so class names classes like soliciting
awesome that I actually I like I prefer
this way to some ways I've done it
previously that's really nice
now I I'm not gonna do it on this one
but I am actually just curious what if
we wanted to do class names like this
but then in addition do some oh no we
wouldn't want to write because this is
the class name it's not direct styles
right okay nevermind nevermind I was
just thinking about the way I did things
on that react native app that I
completed I don't know like two weeks
ago but I suppose that was a different
use case now that I think about it so
please disregard that question let's see
so did we have to bring that
no yes okay let's import class names
here it might already be imported we'll
see
nope all right let's bring that in
import class names and now I lost that
link
there we go class things we have class
names and then actually see did you have
to put that bar sorry okay so we we do
we have to keep okay so we do have to
keep doing classes dot okay that's fine
just wanted to double check
really call that for item okay
let's check this out whoa what's this
give it a refresh
see what's going on mmm I messed
something up let's see what I did let me
whoops there it is
all right
okay so this is this is pretty
interesting so let me let me share this
with you all so harsh it is saying
quickly I'm just going to confirm that
we have the right font no not yet it's
not working yet let me let me go back
okay so classes for item let's make sure
this is what I'm doing 16 pixels
interesting
yeah it looks like it's exactly the same
listen let's make sure we are bringing
in class names okay let's check it out
again let's just do a refresh no huh all
right let's see what's going on here
category
there we go that's what's going on okay
all right so here's what's happening we
are in fact getting this font size but
it's it's it's on the a tag and
somewhere along the line it's being
overridden by this so whoa I was
unintentional uh-huh all right let's see
shoot
hmm
all right is there any way to do there
is link component we are not creating
that right yeah that's reactor router
we need to put this lower down on the
list item text so that was my mistake I
should have never put it on the link so
let's go class name class is the drawer
item and then now we don't need this
anymore and we don't need this save that
and see if that gets us down low enough
oh it doesn't look like it let's see
where I get applied not there here we're
so close um yeah this time
[Music]
and
okay
I don't know how we're gonna get further
down than that okay so what I need to do
is check out the mature UI documentation
to see if there's some built-in way that
I can get at that interior paragraph tag
or override it or something so let me do
that I know my timer is up but I we're
so close I don't want to lose my train
of thought here so let's do this and
then I'll go to the to the live chat so
we had me wait what was it list
I don't text
okay that's actually really helpful
don't know if you saw that I really like
that feature that'd be cool to implement
something like this in some of our
projects so just keep keep that in mind
it can go on the wish list alright so
let's do that
this item text let's see disable to
children will be ratified typography
content what was that what's happening
okay
alright so let's try did we already have
this on let's see
stable typography see if that does it no
it's actually worse interesting it's so
it changed it to a div it still didn't
do we want wait a second
yeah that's not what we wanted at all
all right let's take that out and
instead let's say I'm interested in this
route here
yeah
maybe you have to do an override
okay um let's see
he's in myself her we found her so
property
maybe we can do it like this
yeah
let's try that sorry that text was
probably really small I apologize
so anyway I'm thinking something like
this would let us get at the root
component so in this case we're gonna
want to say classes
I'm gonna try like this first I'm not
sure it'll work but always worth it to
try a simple thing yeah that does not
look like it's the font size we want see
anything happen while we're still
getting it there I wanna refresh
hmm
hmm
okay I'm not sure what the material UI
way of doing this is supposed to be
so let's see Sophia written a better way
to do it is using CSS direct link
opponent so John Hanson says it's
seeming to suggest that Styles need to
be overwritten directly in the component
with CSS the problem is it seems like I
can't get any any deeper in than this
div anything within that I can't touch
so here's what I'm gonna do I'm
certainly open to finding a better way
to doing this at some point but I think
this will work so let's go with let's
get rid of this I'm gonna do a class
name and let's see if we can class name
equals
whoops keep going the wrong way all
right there we go so we got a classic
drawer item on here now let's just put
drawer item P and will do font size 16
pixels important now great that works so
it didn't apply everywhere because we
need to put that class on these places
but you can see this work so we are able
to get down to it so is there a way to
do that in material you eye or within
that JavaScript object where you had a
bunch of thousand potentially I don't
really know but good old normal CSS has
done the job so yeah and I gave this
claim or a warning about using important
on a previous stream so I'm not going to
do it again but just the short version
is don't use important unless you really
really have to alright cool so let's
just add this class on so it applies you
know across the board here and then I
will get to the live chat alright so
let's take this class name too
so you want this on all we also want
this on let's see how did we do this
here we go
and I got this
categories
I'm gonna take out classic mode now
because I don't think I'm gonna add
classic mode I don't think it's
necessary I am gonna keep the help page
which we'll do at some point all right I
think that's it that should be all the
places
I didn't work on this one I thought we
got that one what's going on here
because it's a div let's update our
styles so we want drawer item P and we
want right on div and now let's give it
a refresh no still not interesting
Oh actually hello I see
so in fact drawer item did get placed
right here on that root so we didn't
need droid I'm div what we needed was
just simply draw right on there we go
now it works okay so we got it here
there there take action it's the only
one that's looking still the old size so
we have here
[Music]
all right perhaps I did not get that on
there um that's fine why that's that up
here a bit yeah which one was that take
action yep I did not catch that one
whoops let's grab this class name right
on there we are and that should be it
yep all right who would have thought it
would have been that time-consuming to
change the font size of these once again
sometimes react makes complicated things
simple and simple things complicated I
don't want to blame react completely
here we were trying to do at the
material UI way we went through all the
steps before we decided to you know kind
of come up with our own solution so
don't want to blame don't want to blame
react completely for that okay so that
actually that might be really worthwhile
I mean to be honest with you like it's
not like we had to be geniuses to come
up with that workaround that's like
pretty simple it's just seemed like
there would be some other way with
material you I I think that might be
worthwhile as a some sort of pull
requests to metier you I to come up with
a better way a better way to do that I'm
not sure but
at least a more consistent way right
because for most of the things there's a
certain prop or a way that you would do
things like that and you wouldn't go
directly to the CSS and add your own
classes but then in this case that
seemed to be the only way that it would
work so I would I think it would just be
nice to have some consistency one way or
another either go with everything is
just your own CSS or you know uses
normal CSS classes you're on CSS or
everything has a specific prop in the
mature UI way I mean I don't know does
that make sense I kind of liked to lean
towards the idea of lets us use our own
CSS for a lot of it right they can make
and have classes that are built-in but
then it would be very simple to just say
okay we're gonna be able to edit this in
override classes I mean I just kept I
don't know maybe this is not the case
but it seems to me if you're building
things with react you're probably at the
point where you can certainly manage
your own CSS and if you want to use
what's built in for them wonderful but
then make it the standard way to change
things up should be the same way you
would change things up in any type of
website which would be write some CSS
anyway
I'm not involved with that project so
maybe there is some really good reason
why it's not like that now that I'm
overlooking it's entirely possible I
don't want to be overly critical of the
team that works on material UI it's
certainly been very helpful for some of
my projects so I really appreciate that
all right so now let me answer some
questions here in the live chat
[Music]
let's see
okay I scrolled back way up towards the
top that's where you left off at and we
were talking about optimal font sizes
John Hanson says that his base font size
is 18 pixels so yeah I like that like I
said my base is usually 16 well I
shouldn't say my base my absolute
minimum is 16 so if someone wants to
have like some small text down in the
footer or something like that minimum 16
but the normal text is usually more than
16 pixels but I don't know if you all
run into this issue but I have people
that I make the sites for here you know
people in other departments they seem to
be opposed to this larger font size and
they want it smaller the reason being
they want to fit in as much text as
possible and I've gotten some pushback
on the larger font size and I mean I
just explain every time that this is
much more readable I don't know what
experience you've had with your clients
you know with things like that but also
I usually explain that users aren't
likely to read all that text if even if
you make the text ball and fit in a
bunch of stuff odds are nobody's going
to read all that it's much better to
just get to the point only put what's
really important in there and then have
it readable then people may actually
read it all so I don't know I mean I've
seen some studies and statistics that
seem to suggest that that that I am
taking the correct approach to it but I
would like to hear what you all think
about it as well
I'm always open to changing up the way I
do things if there is some proof that
there's a better way
haha look says a lot of people just do
ctrl+ on all sites to read better yeah
that's I I often do ctrl+ depending on
the site and certainly while I'm
streaming I control plus everything
otherwise you all never be able to see
it but the thing that I worry about is
some users are just very very averse to
any type of technology and I don't know
that they necessarily even know that
they can control Plus and increase the
size so I am very much opposed to the
mindset of thinking as your users as as
less intelligent I I don't like that at
all I think we should respect our users
and try to make things as easy as
possible so I like the idea of assuming
that if there's some easy workaround the
user may not know about it because
they're not really into computers I
think that's perfectly acceptable to
assume that so anyway I just I like I
would like to make that distinction that
assuming that a user doesn't know how to
control + is not the same thing as
assuming that they're not intelligent
they could be very intelligent and just
have invested their time in learning
other things not related to a browser so
anyway that's kind of like it always
bugs me and gets on my nerves when I
hear people talk about users or clients
in a derogatory way like they don't know
what they're doing I mean I'm frustrated
with clients and users frequently but no
need to belittle them in any way
okay
I'm reading down through if you can if
you can see the live chat you know I'm
talking about but if you can't see the
live chat I sort of mentioned so Harshit
who I mentioned frequently because he's
helped out so much with the projects
when sorry I need huh some my throat
okay log data Salesforce okay what I'm
coding and Harsha's trying to get my
attention
it's just like all caps so there are
like sections within the live chat where
it's just know with like a ton of OHS
all caps and so it's it's amusing and I
know sometimes I get into what I'm doing
and I forget to check the live chat so
sorry about that are [ __ ] I appreciate
you not giving up on me and continuing
to try to get my attention
okay good there's a good question here
so not sure
so yes you asked this not sure if you're
still with us yes you but the question
is if we have a separate language for
styling why do you use CSS in JavaScript
that's that's a very good question and a
legit question I can totally understand
that CSS and JavaScript is weird it's
not necessary and react but I believe I
mentioned this earlier but I'm gonna say
it again because I think this this is to
me the answer to why you would do CSS
and JavaScript to have a self-contained
react component so that number one you
could take that component and use it
elsewhere and you'd have everything you
need just plug in your data and you're
good number two it also makes it super
easy for someone to look at your code
look at your component and see the big
the whole picture of how everything is
going to look when you have your styles
in your markup all right there and your
logic because it's JavaScript all right
there so that's the benefit of it I will
say there's other potential benefits
depending on exactly how you're putting
the CSS in your component so I know on
react native when I use create react
native app there was something I believe
it was built in to create react native
app I don't know that it's built in to
react native itself I'm not sure but
there was something that if you used if
you put the CSS in a certain way within
your react component it actually gave
you a performance a slight performance
benefit because of behind the scenes how
those eventually got applied so I don't
know enough about how that JavaScript
gets trance
and becomes Java or Swift or whatever to
know exactly why there's a performance
increase but I do know from from that
Udacity nano degree that I did that
there is a performance increase so I
don't know if there's any similar thing
with regular react that could be done
but it's potentially I mean it's
possible okay John Hanson says a nice
thing is to style the text of flow and
columns as when the width of a single
card view gets too wide it's harder to
read oh I have never thought of that
that's that's interesting that's really
interesting I'm gonna keep that in mind
I'm not sure if I want to change things
up in this project because the users
already have an expectation but that's
really interesting we do have some
upcoming projects within the next few
months that that may come in handy I
really like that idea
okay yes you also asks why don't you
sass or SCSS / CSS to be honest with you
I much prefer s CSS
I actually really like sass you know
plain sass but the only reason I don't
use it is because you can't copy in
normal CSS and have it work if it
weren't for that I'd be using that cuz I
really like the just the indentation
style you can that's the fastest I can
write CSS is by using sass but anyway I
end up using s CSS because it kinda
gives you a little bit of both worlds
the CSS and the SCS SS or an assess this
is some twisters trying to get all those
letters up anyway I do love to use it we
just haven't set it up on this project
to use it but in previous project we
have so whenever possible I do like to
use sass instead if you're not familiar
with SAS or SCSS it's a CSS preprocessor
it lets you do some cool things with
nesting of CSS so I guess a good example
I have a good example here so instead of
doing this where I have this comma so
droid and P and then Troy them I could
potentially do something like this you
know wouldn't that's not a good example
nevermind
uh prints
shoot I don't have a good example here
I'll just have to make one up
so in regular CSS we could do something
like this
where I would say let's just go body a
for all the a tags and then I would put
a CSS something and then so let's just
put that in there just so we have
something and then I would need to do in
CSS let's say I wanted to do body P
right so instead of this with sass I
could write body a I'm obviously this
something is not real CSS so if you're
new to CSS please don't try to type this
in it won't work and then you could
write P right and then whenever it was
all processed it would end up looking
like this but you saved yourself a
little bit being able to do this so it
doesn't really seem like there's much of
a savings this probably takes up the
same amount of lines but it can be very
useful if you get a little bit deeper in
generally you don't want to nest too
deeply maybe just three levels or so but
you could do this so that's the very
basic thing you can also do things like
have variables so you could make a
assess variable and then so let's say we
made this a color variable then
throughout everything we could just say
like this is our primary color we
defined it in one place if later on we
want to change our color scheme all we'd
have to do is change that variable and
it would change throughout so there's
really cool things there's other things
you do with like
it's almost like a blend of a
programming language and CSS so anyway
that's a brief overview of sass or CSS s
CSS I mean so this is s CSS syntax
there's another syntax called sass that
is different but you can do a lot of the
same things with it
okay hard [ __ ] so hard [ __ ] before the
stream sent me a coupon for digitalocean
hard [ __ ] I tried to use the coupon code
and it told me that it wasn't valid so
it ended up not working for me so I
don't know what the problem is but thank
you for sending that I that was that was
really nice of you Joseph
Whittington s so anyone can join this
project definitely anybody is welcome to
submit a pull request to this project or
point out any issues or anything like
that
of course I review all pull requests I
may or may not pull it into the project
but I do my best to pull in everything
that I can so I may ask you to adjust
some things first and then I'll pull it
in but I welcome anybody especially
people who are new if you'd like to get
some experience with pool requests I
know sometimes it can be intimidating to
try to get a pull request submitted to a
larger repository and not everybody is
friendly whenever you submit a pull
request sometimes people are frustrated
or having a bad day and you know I've
had that happen before you submit a pull
request and the maintainer is just
aren't very polite if let's say it
wasn't exactly what they wanted so I'm
not going to do that to anybody so if
you're a little bit apprehensive about
submitting pull requests this is a great
place to get a start I'll do my best to
to try to work with you and get your
pull request merged in
let's see Joseph also says how difficult
do you think it would be trying to learn
react coming from angular for background
I don't know myself because I'm not
super familiar with angular 4 I only
worked with the very you know first
version of angular you know back in the
day so I don't know for sure but I would
imagine if someone had the intelligence
to be able to learn angular 4 they
certainly have the intelligence to learn
react it may be you have to change how
you think about certain things but I
would have no doubt there's no doubt in
my mind that somebody is certainly
capable of learning react if they know
angular
yes us is it worth it to use nodejs
against gulp I'm not entirely sure it's
cool
alright so I'm not entirely sure what
you're asking I'm going to rephrase the
question and see if this is really what
you're asking please correct me if I'm
wrong but are you saying to use like NPM
scripts instead of gulp
so it would just be kind of directly
using the npm scripts that you come with
no js' is it worth it I don't it depends
if you're really used to using gulp and
you have a nice setup and you really
like it I you could certainly do fine
just sticking with that if you're really
worried about the speed and uh you know
optimization of your your development
process your build process I'd say given
PM's scripts a try they're pretty
straightforward I've always kind of
wanted to set up NPM scripts I have in
small projects before but I always just
kept going back to my gulp setup because
it was it already worked so I don't know
like I said it does kind of depend on
you know how many if you plan on like
reusing it for a ton of different
projects then yeah it's it's definitely
worth it it'll save you time you know
potentially in the long run but I think
that's more of a personal choice that in
terms of the end result you can probably
get the same end result with NPM scripts
or with go
Arsen says you know you're a number
three and contributors for the bulletin
I didn't realize I have felt fallen to
number three so thanks for letting me
know yeah so I really only work on the
bulletin whenever I'm streaming so I
have other projects that I need to work
on when I'm not streaming so that's why
my contributions are low I appreciate
everybody else contributing though it's
really amazing
all right cool John Hanson earlier I was
talking about the optimal amount of
words per line for for readability and
John Hanson says it's 80 characters per
line so not not where I'm sorry that I
mistakenly said words you're right John
it is characters so 80 characters is you
know give or take a few but that's the
right spot that you want to be in so if
you if you try for that then it's more
likely that users will read your content
Joseph asks does Google have a style
guide for react not that I know of
not that I know of so that actually
might be good to look into perhaps
instead of creating our own style guide
from scratch for our react projects we
could see if there's a style guide out
there that already kind of fits with
what we're used to using potentially you
can adapt it if we want to but if
anybody knows of a good react style
guide please please let me know and I
can check it out
alright alright so I think I'm almost to
the bottom of the live chat so if you
have a question you haven't put it in
there you have the chat please put it in
there now because I'm nearing the end
okay Humbert Umberto says looking for
sysadmin about to go solo a server boss
so moving from I is from 2008 machine to
a 2012 machine with a separate website
websphere server okay so I don't know
anything about iis servers so I
shouldn't say that I know very little
about iis service so I've worked with
them I've never worked with them
directly only kind of in a research type
of way of helping out other people so if
anybody else can help out with that
please let Umberto know
John Hanson says react is so complex to
get keyboard events like arrow left and
arrow right to iterate through an array
of images as in a slideshow I'm about to
give up on that UI function interesting
I actually have never find any I don't
think I've ever attempted to get arrow
keyboard events to work with react so
I'll take your word for it that it's a
pain actually I am let me tell you about
a project I've been discussing with one
of my co-workers here because it's
really fun and you all please let me
know if any of you are interested in
maybe helping out with it so this would
be a longer-term project but we thought
it would be really cool for students who
are interested in the university to be
able to get kind of a virtual tour of
campus but it would not be like a normal
virtual tour the idea is to create a
game an HTML game right that can play in
the browser or potentially be ported to
mobile and react native but the idea
that it would be like an old-school
8-bit game right so possibly like
top-down view like the original Zelda
game and we would recreate things on
campus and they would have a little guy
that could walk around and see
everything so just a basic thing but but
we thought it would be cool to do it and
react because my colleague really wants
to learn react so he needs to get some
projects using react like that so he
would actually be more of the lead but I
could help out work with it too and we
could potentially work on it during the
stream I don't know I thought it would
be fun to do I've always kind of wanted
to try to do a JavaScript game I think
my kids would really enjoy something
like that so anyway if anybody thinks
that sounds cool or interesting let me
know that maybe I can move forward with
that project but if nobody's interested
then I'm not gonna you know try to put
it on the stream
to do some things that that you are more
interested in you know if possible so
anyway I just thought I'd bring it up
let's see harsh it has reminded me to
commit this that I can let's see good
thanks for reminding me I don't want you
all if you if you want to clone the repo
or you know what for I don't want you to
have the older versions I want you have
the latest one great okay so in is here
hey Anna how's it going
and it says what accomplishment are you
most proud of
well aside from all my kids and getting
married to my wife in terms of what I do
with you know with web development hmm I
want to say like whatever my latest
thing I come out with is always what I'm
most proud of
right so I've been really proud of like
the Resource Center I was really proud
of when I first made it and I got a lot
of great positive feedback but then now
when I look at the original Resource
Center that I made I just see like all
that mess of code so it's got a hard
question to answer with projects like
this you know like we do cuz they get
old you know and you can see the
mistakes as they get old so it's hard to
stay as proud of them as as you know I
was initially but I would I would say I
I did the first react site that I did
for a paying client so it was on the
side it wasn't for the university that
was the first site I think that I ever
that I ever launched that I didn't react
I use neck j/s for server-side rendering
I was pulling in data from the WordPress
API it was very similar to what we did
with catechetical Institute I was really
proud of that I worked on it
she's so much
that was one of my biggest projects for
a client that was that that may have
been the project that I'm most proud of
currently it was great and then it
provided a lot of you know extra income
for my family I got to use a lot of that
money to I bring my wife on a trip that
I was going to a conference and it was
our ten-year anniversary so we were able
to pretend like we were rich for a
couple of days and go to a really nice
restaurants and things so she really
really liked that so that was cool that
that product the project itself I
learned so much on and I worked through
so many things that just made me want to
like quit being a web developer
altogether and just move to a cabin with
no electricity but I worked through it
all and so I was just so relieved and
excited and then the the result you know
the the reward for the work was was
awesome and let me do some nice things
for my family too so anyway sorry I went
on a little bit about that but I never
really thought of it until you asked the
question so I I want to give you good
answer but anyway that's that's my most
the accomplishment that I am most proud
of at least from what I can think of
right now on the spot
okay Harshit mentions that stylus is
even faster to write than sass
interesting I I never tried to use
stylus
it seemed to me stylus was always like
not as widely used on projects than in
SAS I seem to be the front-runner has
anyone else you stylus what are your
thoughts on it
John Hanson says in the react project
I'm doing I did switch from I switched
to s CSS from SAS you are right so easy
to cut and paste style components work
very much like s CSS and J's strings as
in like nested so awesome yes I mean is
it's just it's nice to have the freedom
to pull in CSS from previous projects or
from other frameworks and things and
just have it work and not have to
convert it so yes that that outweighs
the ease of typing in my mind and that
pushed me to use s CSS instead of size
so see
Harshit says I like the the and the
ampersand the most in sass cool
yes that's has some really cool features
like I own the I I don't even use most
of the cool features really I am I don't
think I utilize it as much as I could
but it's really cool
brooke says with using some oh I'm sorry
I skipped a question I I miss Shen sorry
if I'm mispronouncing that says can you
tell me the advantage of using graph QL
or why you would need it okay so for
graph QL in previous projects we use the
WordPress API which is a REST API and
that worked well the problem was
sometimes we had we had to choose there
was a trade-off we could either make
multiple API calls and get exactly the
data that we wanted with those API calls
or we can make one API call and get a
lot more data than we needed with graph
qo you don't have that problem in graph
QL there are not preset endpoints that
you just get all the data from you tell
the API exactly what you need and it
gives you just that data that you need
so you can be more efficient in terms of
both the amount of API calls you make
and the amount of data sent on those
calls so that's why we switched up in
this project to using graph QL I do
think that it is better than a normal
REST API I suspect that in time it will
kind of overtake the REST API s I mean
clearly I think it is it is better so
it's I it's just a matter of time before
more people adopt it okay so rook's
question is would using something like
normalize CSS be beneficial to this
project might just try and do
it to mess around with to get things I
learned
I don't know I'm not sure if normalized
CSS would be beneficial or if
essentially maybe if materialized or I'm
sorry material UI is already taking care
of some of that stuff
does anybody know or has worked with
material UI to know whether or not that
is kind of taken care of I'm not opposed
to bringing into the project if there's
some benefit to it but if it wouldn't be
necessary then it probably better to not
have it in the project so I don't know
offhand I'd have to you know check out
check that out maybe somebody's probably
had a similar thought before so I'm sure
that the answers out there
Harshit says you should upgrade from
node 8.5 to noted 8.9 LTS yeah maybe
I'll all upgraded at some point I really
I really want to get that that
application that we were working on the
styles for that done that salesforce1 so
I'm probably gonna take the rest of the
day and really work on that I did have
some positive feedback from some people
higher up at the University on it but
they did notice some of those things
that that we had noticed that I didn't
complete yet so I told him I was working
on it so I I'd really kind of like to
get it done as soon as possible but yeah
I would like to stay up to date on that
so I will try to get that done soon okay
harsh it says the Airbnb guide is the
best so we're talking about style guides
it forces you to write good code if you
have Lansing an editor cool rook also
agrees about the Airbnb guide and it
says with minimal adjustment you can
make it fit your preferences okay I'm
gonna have to check that out the air the
using the Airbnb guide yes so there are
some adjustments that I would like to
make depending on what's already in the
guide i tell you truth I looked at it a
long time ago I haven't I don't remember
anything from it so I don't have to look
at it again but yeah we should
definitely should that would be a good
practice for people to get used to using
a guide because potentially you might
need to use it yes I get a decent amount
of people who are looking for work and
they're in here just you know trying to
get some experience submit a few pull
requests so it'd be good for them to get
used to that because they may need to
use it on their job so that's a great
reason and then just in general it would
help keep our clip our code better and I
like harsh its idea they're saying it
forces you to write good code let's see
my mission says games are too much work
yeah I agree with you there this would
definitely be if we were to do a game it
would be a long term project I'm talking
like maybe we want to have it done by
next year around this time so we'd
certainly have a lot of time to work on
it so yeah we'll see oh it's not I'm not
convinced yet that we will do it just a
possibility
like I said I think it would be really
cool for the students and it might be
fun for us to make so anyway I
appreciate the input though so anyway if
anybody else has any opinions of that
please let me know
Harshit says might use canvas yeah Oh
Harsha's asking City do you what do you
want to be done this weekend in this
project okay so in the bulletin projects
let's see what do we need done still
just saw something
okay here's something that should be
done but it's it's on the wish list so
here's something that doesn't absolutely
need to be done but it would be awesome
if it could get done this is something
that I wanted to do with the bulletin
since I first launched it last over a
year ago I think it would be really cool
if so right we already have a user we
have their email address right so it
would be awesome if based on their email
address we could display like
potentially up in the corner have a
little circular icon with potentially
maybe just their initials or if they
happen to have their email address
linked up with something like Gravatar
we could pull in their data from their
display their picture I'm thinking like
you know how Google does when you're
logged into Google with some of the
Google stuff you have your picture there
and then when they click on that they
could bring up let's say their profile
in their profile they could if they
wanted to add in their preferred name
and potentially their preferences so
whether or not they want by default the
grid layout or the list layout if they
would like trying to think I would love
to have a way to personalize like what
they see
I also want control of like the very top
area in case there's some emergency
announcement that we need to put there
but maybe what categories they like to
see and yeah I think
you know there's so many things we could
do with that like potentially a history
of all the bulletin announcements that
they've submitted it would be cool to be
able to see that so certainly that
that's definitely on the wish list it
may be complex if you're interested in
taking a shot at something like that
feel free but otherwise there's really
only some small things that need changed
and it's mainly just like UI stuff just
kind of the look style changes so I
don't know that's all I have and I'm
definitely open to suggestions of what
other what functionality should this
have is there something obvious that you
would expect it to have that it doesn't
have something I'm missing or maybe
something less obvious that's just cool
just to reiterate for those of you who
who haven't heard this already
the goal of this is internal bulletin so
it's for university employees only there
they just get announcements about
schedule so any events that are
happening on campus any announcements
about holidays coming up or new
employees or if an employee had a baby
or if there was and one of the employees
relatives passed away you know they'll
put like funeral arrangements stuff in
their announcements from the president
of the university so things like that go
in here so given that given what the
audiences and the content is I'm open to
suggestions so anyway so I know that's
not like super specific hardship so it
may be at this point if anybody wants to
contribute to this project it's it's
kind of like imagination time right I'm
open to other features all right
innocence thanks for answering oh you're
welcome nope
that was a really fun question so I like
that question thanks for asking it
okay so terra incognita says I'm not
sure for my current skill
am I really able to work efficiently on
the oh I'm sorry I think I read that
wrong I'm not sure from my current skill
I'm not sure that I'm really able to
work efficiently on the game project
from my current skill I just rephrase
that a bit it was easier for me to say
but on it on details of that project
might make me confirmed about
contributing on okay so yeah we can if
there's some interest in the project I
could get more so exact some detailed
stuff on exactly how will we be doing it
and so yeah I'll have to think about
that maybe next week sometime I can
devote a little bit of time on the
question and answer to really getting in
more to the details of what we would
want Harshit said stylus is great it
even gets rid of colons and as many
great mix-ins
built-in that's cool Oh or it says view
beautify is the material design
framework for view and its built-in
stylus that's cool Harshit also says
material UI should have a reset like
like normalized okay cool so that's good
to know
let's see
ambition says there's no guide that
allows not ending in semicolons man
that's going to be problem then I've
gotten so used to not putting semicolons
in rook says you can modify the rule
well that's good that's good
it definitely would if we can change
that
then I'm in
let's see I nine mission says how would
you store users history on the web on
the WordPress server or locally okay so
I'm thinking let me let me show you
where's my code so let's check out our
server for a second here yes we got it
off so so like we've already got this
you know [ __ ] store going right this is
MongoDB so I'm thinking we would store
the data there and since we're already
checking it to make sure that the users
like really supposed to be there and
login it shouldn't be too much more of a
stretch to grab all the user data at the
same time so that was my thought if I
were going to do it that's where I would
start out at is well let's store all the
user data in the same place and then
pull it all from there so if there are
better ways to do that I'm definitely
open to that but that was those were my
thoughts and we certainly could store
things in local storage and then just
update as needed I think that's kind of
a good good practice as well let's see
sad tinder says don't be lazy because of
a few viewers bro I'm not exactly sure
what that was in response to that was at
3:45 so I was a couple minutes ago I
remember what I was talking about
so anyway said cinder if you could let
me know what that was what I was talking
about let me scroll back and heap I can
remember
Fabia says awesome hi from Brazil thanks
for sharing the gold with us I'm trying
to follow the subject on the backend
develop a cannoli developer try to use
react in both sides front and back is my
new challenge awesome that's really cool
I really enjoy talking with people that
can't come from back end so like I'm I'm
coming from front end and trying to
learn more backend and I think it's just
an interesting flow of realizing like
what's what's hard about front-end for
people who are normally back in and
coming into it that's kind of cool and
then like what what strengths and
weaknesses do people bring from both
sides so anyway I'm glad to have you
here please feel free to add your input
and your suggestions I'm lacking in the
backend experience I'm getting much
better than I was with back-end even a
few months ago but that's certainly not
I wouldn't call that my strong point now
I'm much more front-end oriented so I
definitely welcome your expertise so
thanks for thanks for saying hi in the
live chat Ryan says good afternoon hey
how's it going let's see
Harshit says i'm back my laptop battery
died okay cool
glad you're back and let's see okay you
picked it up on the phone harsh it says
okay so hard should learn back in first
as well that explains why your expertise
then with with back-end so that's
awesome yeah I like I said I it's always
crazy like there are things that
front-end people seem or like all that's
so easy but then you talk to back in
person and they're like no way I don't
mess with that and then vice versa
there's stuff that - a background person
a back-end person is like oh yeah no
problem but a front-end person like me
will just stare at that like I have no
idea what's going on here so anyway it's
cool I think it's great to have people
of all different backgrounds and skill
sets
it just makes our project so much better
and being able to share all that
knowledge it's really cool I don't know
of anywhere else with this kind of thing
is happening where we have such a large
diverse community all working on
projects together I know what happens on
github but like in terms of the live
stream and being able live to work with
each other on this I haven't seen
anything like it before I think it's
awesome see Ryan says I'm learning how
to do react from working with PHP in my
sequel development on a programming
career okay cool I'm really glad that we
have someone with PHP my sequel
knowledge because we're definitely we're
running WordPress for for several
different sites and it's awesome that
you're here and I you know please feel
free to when we work on PHP stuff which
we do occasionally feel free to let me
know I could do it better
ambition says back-end is way more open
front-end is all just JavaScript yeah
yeah you're right about that that's a
good and a bad thing if you want to do
front-end there's no confusion about
what language to learn javascript is it
but at the same time if you don't really
like JavaScript you're stuck with it
glib says hello from Moscow hey how's it
going thanks for joining us what time is
it in Moscow right now it's got to be
pretty getting pretty late right
okay terra incognita so sorry about the
missing words in my last comment thanks
for flying oh don't worry about it I
mean I'm like not a problem it was more
just me trying to read it too fast those
confusing so I'll follow the updates
that's coming soon and I'm definitely
interested in working with this current
project alright great
great I'm looking forward to to you
working on this so awesome Ryan says
I've been trying to follow your videos
on react and learn more front-end
frameworks cool hopefully they've been
helpful to you let me know if there's
anything I'm not going over that you'd
like to know about or somehow I could
improve the experience so I actually
don't often get suggestions on how I do
these things the only suggestion that I
used to get consistently was you talk
too much code more and then I've tried
to do that but I want to make this as
good as I can in terms of my
contribution to the stream so
suggestions are welcome Robert says I
learned something new every live stream
thanks awesome I'm so happy to hear that
I'm really like that's what keeps me
going as long as I know that there's
some benefit for you all from this dream
I will keep going it definitely benefits
me but if it benefits you all and a
benefits free code camp I'm gonna keep
going for as long as my boss will let me
do this and even then if my boss says
you're not allowed to stream from work
anymore I'm going to try to figure out
some way to keep doing it outside of
work or somehow because I think this is
a really cool thing we have going here
alright gleb says yeah it's 11:00 p.m.
here okay cool thanks for staying up
late to watch this I mean 11:00 may or
may not seem late depending on whether
you're a night person or not but I don't
know I have a little kid so 11 seems
late to me now Jimmy says hi are you
gonna make
a tutorial on angular I don't have any
plans to do in angular tutorial right
now I certainly don't feel confident
enough in my angular skills which are
pretty much non-existent to be able to
teach other people but free code camp
does have someone that's doing an
angular project right now so I think
last week at some point that video was
published so just check back a little
bit in the in the videos and in the list
of free code cam videos and you'll see
one that's at the beginning of an
angular tutorial so I haven't watched it
yet but I'm assuming that it's good
quality I mean everybody is really
knowledgeable and does a great job here
on on this channel I don't know if I
want to include myself in that category
you all see how many times I mess up my
stream but all the other people are
really knowledgeable so so check that
out Harshit says it's 1:25 a.m. where
he's yeah I figured that it was it was
even later there and so I usually don't
ask how late it is over there because I
have so many people from that area of
the world that I've like I can usually
always figure out what time it is
they're just from from hearing it so
much in the live stream alright Ryan
says I'm looking at using react and
redux for building an e-commerce store I
have a client that would like one built
on the framework react that's really
cool trying to think I I kinda remember
somebody doing something similar and
telling me about it recently but I
cannot remember who it was if anybody
watching now was the person that
recently built some ecommerce stuff with
react let me know it's possible I may
have just seen somebody on Twitter talk
about it and then I I viewed it so it
may not have been directly to me man I
really wish that I could remember what
that was so I could give you a link to
it
now that would help out but that's
really awesome I'm interested in seeing
what you come up with so I don't know if
this is possible but if you're allowed
to have the code on github available
like publicly available I'd love to see
that that repository and if I have time
I I may even help out with it and and
submit a pull request but let let me
know if it's possible to then please
send me the link
and I think that'd be really cool
Harshit says to do the e-commerce thing
use Gatsby maybe Flipkart uses Gatsby it
react witches as it's as large as Amazon
here okay awesome
okay cool all right well I've gotten to
the bottom of the live chat and it's
getting nearly time for me to to wrap
things up here and go home for the
weekend so thank you so much for all
your your help in this stream and I hope
I hope you'll learn something from it I
know I did and I will be back I should
be back Monday I have to go see a doctor
about getting surgery done on my wrist
but that's in the morning on Monday
hopefully my appointment isn't really
long so I should be okay to stream again
on Monday
and yeah so everybody have a great
weekend and I'll see you next week